jim cramer everyone loves jim kramer
madden money cnbc contributor host he
now thinks that the stock market is full
of absurdity which is a great line from
jim he essentially has come out and said
all sorts of different things we're
gonna go through these various quotes
from i think we got four of them first
of course when a linkage gets
jesus christ jim attenated
attenuated attenuated it makes you
wonder
of course when a linkage gets you
iglooed
it makes you wonder if the market has
completely lost its mind do we really
believe apple's stock should rally if
natural gas falls from six dollars to
five dollars and fifty cents he's
specifically talking about a linkage
between natural gas and technology stock
saying that the rising price of natural
gas is playing a big part in the recent
move in higher bond yields and also
plays into investors inflation fears so
the whole idea is that now he's making a
assumption or a linkage between natural
gas and technology stocks natural gas
goes up or down stocks are going up and
down as a response so second quote here
is apple's market capitalization might
literally grow by 50 billion dollars if
natural gas breaks down below 5.50 cents
even though there's no direct core
connection but like it or not that is
how this market works at least for the
moment so again he's talking about that
there is this correlation between
natural gas and the technology stocks
which goes back to his idea of this is
absurd there's no natural connection
between those two things but that's
what's happening and then he says quote
it's not just the tech natural gas
linkage this market's full of absurdity
so this is just one of many things that
he has identified and then lastly he has
a comment about worry parker which had
its market debut on wednesday of last
week they went public via direct listing
the stock closed at 55 dollars up about
40 percent from its 40 reference price
and worry parker is now valued more than
six billion he said last year warby
parker raised a bunch of money at a
three billion dollar valuation and
almost nothing has changed since then so
either the people who got in on the last
round of private fundraising are some of
the savviest investors in the world or
the people buying it up here today are a
bunch of suckers i'm guessing the latter
which are pretty strong words coming
from jim cramer but i do think that
warby park is probably the better
example easier to understand for folks
is uh last year they raised money at a 3
billion valuation most of the
fundamentals and the financials of the
business have not changed all of a
sudden now the company is valued at
almost 6 billion so almost 2x in
valuation and all they did was they now
got market liquidity there should be
some liquidity premium meaning that as
soon as they're able to expose it to
more investors if investors like the
company it should trade up because
there's a
wider group of people who want the
demand but this is a perfect example of
why so many of the hedge funds and
public market investors are now pushing
into the private market if there is no
difference between the business for the
most part between last year in the
private market and now in the public
market of course these public market
investors want to buy it earlier they
want to go buy that pre-ipo round so
they can get it at three billion and
then it's gonna pop and it's gonna be 6
billion and then they likely will sell a
big portion of what their position is so
that ends up being a driving force for
public market investors to go into the
private market on top of that you have
these absurdities that kramer keeps
referencing in terms of linkage between
natural gas and technology stocks or
companies that are going public and just
immediately trading up without any
change of the finances or the
fundamentals
are we worried about that continuing to
happen is there anything around the
stock market that we think is actually
real at this point the correlation
between natural gas and bonds and tech
technology is a little concerning and
that's a little absurd to be honest but
the warby parker thing isn't really
shocking to me right public market
guides hands on a stock when it ipo'd
and the price went up makes sense to me
joe what do you think yeah i agree i
mean look there's a lot of absurdity
in the market i don't think uh most
logical people would argue against that
i think it's just kind of filtering out
and finding where the true value is uh
but yeah you look at uh some of the
stocks and kind of the uh what's
happened over the last year not even in
the public markets but in the private
markets also with some of the funding
announcements that have happened uh and
some of the the ways that these
companies have aggressively started to
compound their valuations and grow over
time on a multiple basis is really quite
scary when you look at it there's just
so much capital and inflows into the
system right now that people are just
looking for investments right and
they're going further out the risk curve
and they're doing things that they
normally typically wouldn't do in a
normal in a normal cycle
so we'll see i think um time will tell
obviously like when kind of the market
declines over time people naturally get
more scared like this isn't it's
certainly uh unique but it's not
something we haven't necessarily
never seen before like when people lose
money in the stock market if it ever
goes down and stuff like this it pulls
back that risk curve and people start to
be a little more
cautious with their money so i think the
linkage is kind of a little scary right
now but over time it will correct itself
do we feel like there is just pure
arbitrage going on between those late
stage private market rounds and the
public market or do we think that
there's potentially in uh information
that the public market investors have
that the private market doesn't and
that's why they're willing to trade up
you're talking about it like when they
ipo yeah like why is it trading up is it
because there's actually a difference in
the evaluation or is it just because
people are being stupid polita i think
people are just being stupid like
[Laughter]
i i remember when i was at fortune last
year and all these private companies
were like ooh i think we're gonna delay
our ipo because we don't know how the
virus will affect the markets and then
we've seen quite the opposite with all
these companies now rushing to go public
because
people are gonna
i think i also think that there is uh
people don't value the disconnect
between uh the amount of people that
want to invest in private companies but
do not have access to do so right so
when that stock becomes public there's a
mad rush of not only people but cash
into these assets that people want to go
do so that's why you normally see some
of this pop
and then it just depends on kind of how
many shares you're outstanding what kind
of the economics look like on it and
yeah 30 35 40 percent jump uh on day one
is is that's a lot uh but ultimately is
it really right like and this was a
direct listing this wasn't an ipo where
they manipulate the price lower the
direct listing
but people want access to these
companies right and it's companies that
warby parker is kind of one of those
trendier names or those companies that
has uh that a lot of people have been
interested over the last few years it
was the first time they had access to it
in the public markets they went about
the stock 30 40 a lot but no one would
have said anything it was 10 15 20.
along this point do we think that
there's a big correlation between the
people who want these stocks and that's
why all of the spax and all of those
types of stocks exploded is because they
felt like they were getting access to uh
what would have been private companies a
little bit earlier and so they wanted to
go ahead and jump in i don't know like
the smack market was absurd i think that
was like one of the most absurd things
uh but yeah it speaks to it like we
everyone like spax were essentially just
literally there was hundreds of specs
going around just offering people uh
shares in the space advisory roles cash
whatever it was entertainers athletes
anyone right anyone famous just to
attach their name to these things and
get them to trade a little higher uh so
i think that was more of an example of
like too much capital in the system and
people looking to make investments but
like
i don't know warby parker robin hood all
these companies that were like popular
in people's minds over the last three
four five years going public you can see
why those would appreciate in value 63
of the u.s ipos this year ben's backs
that's crazy 63 of all u.s ipos 709 us
ipos
447 specs but we've already seen that's
already falling off over the last two
three months most of it was in february
yeah you know those views this whole uh
market mechanism the other piece of it
that's really interesting to me is um
look at what we did from the uh the
venture fund standpoint right when we
went out on our own uh what i was able
to do was go directly to the people
right have a larger social following go
directly to the people get them to
invest and say look i don't need any
institutions it's literally just the
people themselves and then over time as
more institutions say hey we want to
participate as well you can bring
institutions in but you can go to the
people first and then institutions
second what's up guys bang bang a bunch
of you want to bring that trillionaire
energy every day and if you want to do
it in your financial life go use sofi
sofa is our exclusive sponsor because we
think they've got a great piece of
software that'll help you accomplish
your financial dreams go to sofi.com
today to get started you can invest in
everything from etfs to individual
stocks to cryptocurrencies to ipos and
they even have an automated and best
function head on over to sofi.com today
and make sure you come back tomorrow to
watch more of the best business show
[Music]